>>VOICEOVER: From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>>HERB: One of the most
difficult things I had to deal
with when I learned I had
impaired my vision was that I
wouldn't be able to read. When
people alerted me to the Library
of Congress program, I realized
I could listen.
>>MARY: There's all kinds of
formats that you can choose
from. You can choose from large
print or braille or audio. What
I love about the audio books is
that I could be cooking and I
could be listening to a book.
>>MELANIE: I love audio books,
but there are times when, for
me, for a number of reasons, I
just like to be able to feel the
braille under my fingers.
>>YASMIN: The books, they come
in the mail. The mailman drops
them in my mailbox. I have a big
mailbox for that purpose.
>>PETE: The equipment is loaned
to you by the library. And when
you finish reading a book, you
turn the mailing card over, and
it goes straight back.
>>EDDIE: The NLS has pretty much
anything you'd possibly want to
read, from fiction to
educational materials.
>>TERIANA: It has expanded my
horizon because I'm trying to
learn some more.
>>PETE: Everybody can read the
way they want to read using
this program.
>>NARRATOR: Visit
loc.gov/ThatAllMayRead or call
1-888-NLS-READ to learn more
about the Library of Congress
braille and talking book
program. Apply for NLS today.
>>VOICEOVER: This has been a
presentation of the Library of
Congress. Visit us at loc.gov.